you know it's something that I noticed
you obviously this very public role
before in Congress running the freedom
caucus senator you still have a very
public role but your job now mr. meadows
is a little bit more of a
behind-the-scenes job could you maybe
take us behind the scenes a little bit
into what that day looks well obviously
they've got cameras rolling here so I
don't know there'll be too much behind
the scenes but I will say this you know
since I've come over and we're almost at
day 85 on this job I've done no press so
it's it's it is a behind the scene so to
bring everybody behind the scenes I
think that the real key is I see the job
is to serve the President of the United
States who serves the American people
but it's also to make sure that every
good idea that is in the Senate yeah
gets the visibility with the president
United States in a nanosecond and so one
of the things that people don't realize
is that I can get a phone call from
senator Cruz or a Senator blunt or
Lindsey Graham and they're saying you
know listen we've got this this issue we
need you to take care of it sometimes
it's just as simple as we've got some
constituents that have raised this
concern we want to make sure the
president the United States knows about
it and Ted Ted can vouch for this it's a
phone call and within minutes the
President of the United States is
weighing in on that particular issue
is nothing like anything I've ever seen
and it's trying to be the gatekeeper
behind the scenes that maybe is not as
much of a gatekeeper is is their
megaphone within the West Wing and so
senators have better access I think did
this president then yep
historically has been the case I think
that's a good thing
the closer the president is to the
American people the more he hears from
from the people of Texas through through
Ted or the the people of South Carolina
through Tim Scott or Lindsey Graham or
whichever senator it might be the better
off it is and so but it's also the power
of the executive branch you know when
when I was in Congress I saying boy all
I wanted to do is make sure that
was empowered well it's a little bit
different role now but if we work hand
in glove I think what we can do this
president is willing to do things that
most presidents are not willing to do
and take political risk
yeah we've been we have an embassy that
in in Jerusalem is something that Ted
and I share passionately together that
would it's been promised before you know
and and it never happened it's a
Republican and Democratic presidents
have broken that promise hey Hannah
Trump is the first one to follow through
I make a confession when president Trump
when he was running and he said I'm
gonna move the embassy in Israel to
Jerusalem I just didn't believe him I
said that's the sort of thing people say
but then they don't actually do it and I
think a lot of people in Washington
thought that and then when it actually
happened everybody was so surprised one
thing that's really unusual in this
administration is the kind of lead
person on Israel policy has been the US
ambassador to Israel David Friedman who
great guys become a close friend and
it's unusual I don't know of any
instance where the ambassadors had that
kind of influence and it's because the
president knows and trust him and David
is is passionately committed to
strengthening the us's relationship but
I worked very closely with David after
the president made the announcement yeah
his look the nature of Washington the
swamp a State Department Foggy Bottom
did not want this to happen so here's
how they would normally kill it they
would just slow roll it we need to study
for a year than feasibility we need to
do a security assessment we need to we
need to do this and that and their plan
it was clear what their plan was gonna
be delay it for years Geoffroy they were
hoping Trump loses re-election and then
the next the Democrat who comes in will
cancel the announce right and and what
the Trump administration didn't David
was the point person I said David the
only way this happens is if you opened
the damn embassy you don't announce it
right you open it and they found a
facility it was a consular facility in
Jerusalem and within a year open the
damn thing I've never seen anything like
it and any there hasn't been a city and
and the bureaucracy at state was shocked
yeah but but that your gala scene like
the urgency of understanding oh and so
true and you talk about behind the
scenes so one story
I don't think is out there is so the
State Department pushing back you know
continuing to push back I think they
gave a list of the pros and cons and so
there were a whole long list of all
these cons yeah zero pros for me yeah so
that's something that better get
reported so it literally was you got all
these reasons not to do it and no
reasons to do it and yet this president
stayed true to his campaign promise and
but but it takes the encouragement
sometimes it's a phone call from Ted
Cruz in the middle of the night saying
you know golly it's the right thing to
do and in that affirmation makes a big
deal well this is what you said earlier
is very interesting to me this idea that
the chief of staff is the gatekeeper but
the flipside is it means you are the
megaphone for good ideas you're the
megaphone for ideas that you're hearing
from people let me give a real-time
example so so Marc's been in office a
couple of months yeah
remember a couple of months ago the
president was meeting with CEOs a bunch
of big oil company yeah and and I was
really worried that at the time and when
the meeting was initially announced it
was just the CEOs of the giant companies
and so I called mark and I said well
this is a real problem because the way
energy works yeah they're a bunch of
small independent producers a lot of
guys in Texas that aren't the you know
giant super majors that have the GDP of
a country but they're the innovators
they're the ones that drive the domestic
production and early on they were not on
the meeting invite list and so I called
Mark said look this is a real problem we
need to make sure we've got an
independent producer there mark not only
got it done but but said look you need
to be there and I got on a plane the
next day if I could was funny when I
walked in there a couple other senators
there they said what the hell are you
doing here and it was because mark said
come to the meeting and at that meeting
you would talk about real action we
pressed a couple of things remember
price of oil was collapsing millions of
jobs we're jeopardy and two things came
out of that meeting number one the
president leaned in hard against the
Saudis and the Russians and got them to
back off their economic warfare against
the US right but number two the
president directed I suggested to the
president it was a real problem of
capital being cut off from energy right
and and I suggested you do resident if
you would you would instruct the
Secretary of Energy Danbury yet it was
there the secretary of the Treasury
Stephen minuchin yeah to make sure that
that Wall Street doesn't discriminate
against energy a bankrupt every US
energy producer and the president right
there said do it he looked at dan and
said make it happen and that made a real
real difference in terms of capital
being available and literally saving
millions of jobs in this country hey
Michael Knowles here and the fact is a
life of cigars and scotch
does not come cheap so please be sure to
subscribe to The Daily wire on YouTube
because I depend heavily on your support
to continue this wonderful Lib
triggering life thanks